on Tuesday president from speaking from
Judea and Samaria while standing next to
master terrorist supporter Palestinian
dictator Mahmoud Abbas tore into the
Islamic terrorists responsible for the
bombing of an ariana grande concert in
Manchester on Monday evenings had so
many young beautiful innocent people
living and enjoying their lives murdered
by evil losers in life I won't call the
monsters because they would like that
term they would think that's a great
name
I will call them from now on losers
because that's what they are they're
losers and we'll have more of them but
they're losers just remember that some
on the left predictably thought Trump's
language was childish Oona Haj dari said
Trump on the Manchester attack so many
people killed by evil losers he sound
like a high school girl reacting to her
hair being pulled Alan Greenspan Trump
sounds like a third-grader name-calling
terrorist evil losers is this how a
president is supposed to act here's the
thing Trump is 100% absolutely
positively correct every time there is
Islamic terrorist attack people
immediately jump to trying to understand
the mind of the terrorists what drove
him to blow himself up in a pizzeria or
at a dance club what made him pick up a
gun and mow down patrons in a gay bar
why would you drive a truck through a
Christmas market we all know the answer
Islamic extremism but by constantly
asking the question and then answering
it with various laments about poverty or
lack of opportunity we put the onus on
ourselves to answer the charge implicit
in terrorism that the terrorists are the
actual victims that they've somehow been
wronged here's the truth
they haven't been wronged they are as
President Trump says evil losers they
deserve no answer they deserve no
sympathy they require no explanation
from us those who would murder children
at a pop concert ought to be killed at
the earliest available opportunity and
we shouldn't bother trying to decrypt
how the monsters were created that's
because they're not monsters at all
they're human being to believe evil
things and they are losers who aren't
winning any battles in heaven or on
earth their names will disappear from
history and their souls burn in hell
eternally Trump is also right we must
stop using the language of strength to
describe those who act out of weakness
if you have to blow up thirteen-year-old
girls listen continue pop material
you're not a powerful monster you're a
worm a feeble piece of human refuse we
should describe terrorists with contempt
not filled them up in their own minds
Islamic terrorists feed off the notion
that the West lives in fear of them we
live in fear of things they will do
obviously but we don't live in fear of
them because they're ridiculous puny
human beings ridiculous and puny human
beings can harm
people - but handing them an unearned
moniker like monster scary by nature is
counterproductive and busi goes where no
boost is necessary so good for Trump
Trump knows well how does it mean people
and make them feel smaller and Islamic
terrorists should be made to feel small
they should be scorned derided mocked
treated as small they're not martyrs
they're not warriors they're not victims
they're evil losers I'm Ben Shapiro this
is the Ben Shapiro show so obviously
horrific terrorist attack in Manchester
UK last night we now know more about the
the person who is responsible for this
horrific terror attack apparently he was
British born known to authorities prior
to the attack his name was Abadie I
guess in Psalm Inaba t 23 years old and
the isis claims isis claims dobby was a
Caliphate soldier they've claimed
responsibility for the attack CBS News
says that another person has been
arrested in southern Manchester in
connection with the attack
officials believe only a single device
was planted at the arena they've
detonated another in South Manchester so
I guess that there was another one that
was out there and the it was one of the
people who was killed was an
eight-year-old girl they're a bunch of
an 18 year old woman in 26 year old John
Atkinson of the injured 59 were taken to
the hospital of which at least 12 were
children and we always forget by the way
that when there's a bombing like this
the people who are injured not just
people who are wounded the people are
injured sometimes have their lives
ruined because if you catch a bolt to
the brain it's going to destroy your
life if you lose leg if you are if
you're grievously wounded in sensitive
areas of the body then it can destroy
your life whether or not you die we tend
to look at the death toll but not at the
wounded toll and that's a mistake
we'll talk more about all of this but
first we want to say thank you to our
sponsors over at zip recruiter are you
hiring well now is the time for you to
fill the job that you've needed to fill
and to do it right we know that we need
to do that over the Daily wire which is
why we at the Daily wire use zip
recruiter on a routine basis we know
better than anyone that filling a job
correctly is really tough which is why
we have so many bad people here and
we've started to use zip recruiter to
replace them it's hard to find good
people and if you cast a net in the
wrong way then you end up with an inbox
filled with bad resumes and that's why
you need zip recruiter with zip
recruiter you can post your job to 100
plus job sites with just one click and
then they have great technology that
efficiently matches the right people to
your job better than anybody
zip recruiter doesn't depend on
candidates finding you it finds them in
fact over 80% of jobs posted on zip
recruiter get a qualified candidate in
just 24 hours you don't have to juggle
emails or calls to your office their
system allows you to screen rate and
manage candidates all in one place with
their easy-to-use dashboard right now my
listeners can post jobs on zip recruiter
for free that's right you can do it just
for free go to zip recruiter comm slash
daily wire that zip recruiter comm slash
daily wire and you can post your jobs
right now for free again that zip
recruiters comm slash daily where we use
it here at the office and you should use
it too okay so yesterday when this
attack is going down I'm watching CNN
because I'm at the gym and I can't
change the channel and while I'm
watching it it's it's I start my phone
starts buzzing and it starts buzzing
because the attack is happening but CNN
isn't covering the attacks CNN is
covering the Trump Russia allegations
will get to all of that a little bit
later but if you look at the media news
this morning you can see that while Fox
News has been amply covering the
Manchester attack a lot of the other
networks have already moved on from the
Manchester attack and they're talking
about John Brennan former head of the
CIA speaking with Congress or they're
talking from Prussia and you can see the
priorities that the media have here
regardless of what you think of
President Trump regardless of whether
you think that he is corrupt or whether
he colluded which there's no evidence he
did regardless of what you think the big
news story yesterday was none of the
Trump Russia stuff it was the fact that
there was an evil terrorist who blew
himself up in the middle of an ariana
grande concert and murdered 22 people
and another 59 injured that is the big
story of yesterday if Barack Obama were
president I promise you the media would
be covering it while the wall because
Trump is president they cover it
sporadically so they can say that they
did it but they don't cover at Walden
Wall in any serious way and Trump does
get credit for calling this out in a way
that Obama never did I think that Trump
is right on point when he says what he
says about these people being evil
losers here as President Obama making
this comment is from Bethlehem news clip
13 so many young beautiful innocent
people living and enjoying their lives
murdered by evil losers in life
I won't call them monsters
because they would like that term they
would think that's a great name I will
call them from now on losers because
that's what they are they're losers and
we'll have more of them but they're
losers just remember that and I think
that he's totally right and this is
something worthwhile for Trump's a guy
called Mo Bamba for obvious it's Trump
and Trump is 100% right when the left
starts ripping on him for saying stuff
like this this is why Trump is more
popular among a certain segment of the
population than the Democrats and you
can certainly see that because Trump
does something that I think the rest of
us need to recognize it's not our job to
identify why evil people believe evil
things it is our job to destroy the evil
people you know in the best movie
villain of all time is the Joker in
Batman and one of the reasons the Joker
in Batman is such a great movie villain
is because you don't know his background
two or three times in the film The Joker
starts to tell about how he his face is
carved up and tells different stories
and the purpose of that is to
demonstrate that true evil doesn't need
a rationale true evil doesn't need a
reason now we know the rationale for
Islamic terrorism and it is an
interpretation of Islam that justifies
jihad we know that that's a widespread
interpretation of Islam this is not a
minor strain inside Islam there probably
tens of millions of people at the least
to believe that maybe hundreds of
millions who believe it but that said
what Trump is doing here by saying
listen I'm not interested in doing a
psychological study a psychological
profile of these losers is he's
demeaning them in a way that they ought
to be demean the left meanwhile is
trying to come up with reasons why the
West is actually responsible for this so
we can solve all of the problems I think
that's because for a lot of folks on the
Left they're looking for a solution to
terrorism that doesn't involve just
killing as many terrorists as humanly
possible on the right people seem pretty
willing to go - okay let's go as many of
these people as possible to humiliate
them let's destroy them
let's what month basically are on the
left it's got to be well if we just were
nicer in a certain way if we just if we
just focused on income inequality if we
just focus on global warming maybe all
of that would change so take for example
Chelsea Clinton so Chelsea Clinton is
being pushed by the left and some
newfangled Democrat who's going to come
along and save them listen if your last
hope is
Chelsea Clinton folks you're done as a
party if Chelsea Clinton is your great
hope for a resurrection as part of your
finish she was discussing it some sort
of Women's Conference the the inter
linkage when she called the
interconnections between child marriage
right we're talking about the rape of
small children and climate change watch
watch this is how Democrats tend to
think about terrorism does how they tend
to think about radical Islam I think
it's part of this broader network of
thinking and it's just idiotic which is
to be able to kind of carry multiple
concerns and both our head and our heart
I'm just listening kind of to the
concerns around education and climate
change kind of women's health you know
child marriage access to technology all
of those are of course interconnected we
have to focus on each of them kind of in
their interconnectedness and also its of
individual outrages occasion Jenny looks
but meaningless bullcrap and this is why
when Trump said during the campaign bomb
the crap out of them except didn't use
word crap a lot most Americans I would
say resonated to that because what the
hell is this supposed to mean if the
left's perspective on terrorism is well
it's all interconnected you know
technological change and climate change
and child marriage okay you explain to
me how I do not having access to an
iPhone is responsible from raping an 11
year old girl you slain that one to me
Chelsea Clinton why it is that we
shouldn't respond to that guy by locking
him up or killing him as opposed to I
don't know talking about whether we can
expand broadband to Pakistan like but
this is why people don't resonate to the
left on these issues this is why when
people tend to think about threats
foreign they immediately resonate to to
what people on the right tend to say
Chelsea Clinton continued along these
lines she she says Islamophobia is not
an option I think though that we also
have to recognize particularly at this
moment that sexism is not an opinion as
long as though be is not an opinion
racism is not an opinion homophobia is
not an opinion jingoism is not an
opinion and so I think we in our posture
of listening also have to get
comfortable with standing up and
speaking out be
because I also great kind of it for
those of us that have been blessed and
by definition all of us on this and the
stage today has been blessed there is a
responsibility with kind of giving voice
to the voiceless but also using our
voices okay this is insanity
I just want to show you this is footage
from the explosion last night in
Manchester here's what it looked like in
Manchester last night are we looking at
is this the lobby party yeah so that was
that's actually in the station so as we
was coming out the arena just before
ariana finished along song to try and
beat the rush we come out a few minutes
early with Queen just out of where the
box office is situated in the arena and
then you go into the train station as we
get to the top of the stet we heard the
biggest explosion it was literally about
20 meters from where we stood everyone
started panicking with it we initially
thought it was a terrorist attack
because that's just what what were what
you think because of what's going on we
heard what we was actually in the
building when one-one-one-one went off
and then as we left that's when the
second explosion was to take a little
once we'd already left the building and
we just ran to the car like didn't stop
running there was lots of parents stood
there and I said look at them all
waiting for the kids because I've never
seen it like that before like so many
people so obviously they was waiting for
the children to come all the way in the
people will be was the people because 20
seconds there and was watching for the
steps that's when it that's when it went
off and that before video not to make
you cry so it's it's the parents waiting
for their kids to come out of the
concert as parents do with things like
this riffing it's just horrific and
we're hearing Islamophobia is not an
opinion jingoism is not an opinion so
basically I'm hearing from Chelsea
Clinton in these two clips and obviously
we were done right before the terrorist
attack what doesn't change the
underlying idea in any way because we've
had terrorist attacks before and we'll
have them again when Chelsea Clinton
says all of these things are
interconnected right climate change and
child marriage and and then she says but
you know we really have to crack down
and Isla is Islamophobia and jingoism
hey when I watched the footage of young
girls being blown up
Manchester yeah I have a three and a
half year old daughter I have a
one-year-old son the idea that anyone
would target them in terrorist attack
makes me so enraged I want a bullet
through the brain of these Islamic
terrorists it now forever okay these
people should be tortured in hell they
should never stop burning in Judaism
we're not big on everlasting hell
whatever we believe about everlasting
hell I hope it applies to the fullest
extent to the people who did these sorts
of things and I'm not interested in your
explanations about interconnectedness
and technological innovation and Islamic
terrorism I'm not interested in your
justifications for Islamic terrorism I'm
not interested and why you think that my
expression about terrorism my opinions
of radical Islam should be forbidden but
we should worry about interconnectedness
and justification when it comes to the
people who blow themselves up I'm not
blowing myself up I'm trying to stump in
favor of killing the people who are
going to blow us up but according to
Hillary according to Hillary Clinton's
daughter according to Chelsea the big
problem here is that Islamophobia and
jingoism are going to are going to rise
they're not even opinions we should
restrict those opinions in fact there's
a story today there's a woman in Britain
who is now being basically prosecuted or
investigated by the by the authorities
in Britain because she had the temerity
to point out that there's a connection
to Islam here that there's a connection
to Islamic terrorism which of course
there is it this is why no one takes a
left seriously when it comes to
terrorism now with all of that said the
rights going to have to do better in
providing actual solutions to terrorism
now some of the solutions that have been
proposed some of the things like
president Trump's Muslim ban which he
proposed a while back you know that's I
still think I don't know that's gonna be
effective because I'm not sure how you
screen that but the idea of restricting
immigration from Islamic countries
without being able to vet people
absolutely 100% correct the idea that
we're going to have to take a militant
stance on Isis and wipe them off the
face of the earth and we can't wait
around let the Saudis do it cuz they're
not going to we can't wait around let
the Turks do it because they're not
going to we can't wait around for Iran
to do it cuz they're not going to if you
want these sorts of things to stop
there's going to have to be some
contingent policy and we're going to
talk about that in just a second is all
going to have to be a change in the
mindset of a lot of people on the on on
all sides of the political aisle with
regard to the civilizational battle that
we face
Trump was wrong yesterday when he said
it's not a clash of civilizations it
certainly is a clash of civilizations
that doesn't mean everyone in the Muslim
world is on the side of the Islamic
terrorist civilization but there is a
civilization that is rife with Islamic
terrorism and that the West pretends
doesn't exist but we'll talk about that
in just a second first I want to say
thank you to our sponsors over at M VMT
so do you see this super cool watch this
super cool watch could be or if we have
to shop at MB MT I have two other
watches but this is really the only one
that I wear and that's because it is
sleek and it is cool and it is
comfortable and is minimalist but sort
of what their their designs are famous
for over an MV MT this sort of
minimalistic design I want to show it
takes it's really cool it looks like the
thousand dollar watch but this thing
costs well under 200 bucks that's
because MVM T's goal is to charge
revolutionary prices for the nicest
watches the company was started by two
Broke college kids who wanted to wear
expensive watches but they couldn't
afford them so instead they went and
borrowed some money and started their
own watch company a movement watches MV
MT watches started just 95 bucks at a
department store a watch like this going
to cost you hundreds and hundreds of
dollars if you're looking at other
watches will cost four or five hundred
bucks 95 bucks over an MV MT and they
can do that because they're selling on
lines they cut out the middleman there
goes that giant markup
it's classic design quality construction
style minimalism over 1 million watches
sold in over 160 countries right now you
get 15% off today with free shipping and
free returns if you don't like it by
going to MVM t.com shapiro MVM t.com /
shapiro you get 15% off today so getting
an inexpensive watch you can get even
more inexpensively by going to MVM t
comm / apparel also use that flash
appear so they know we sent you you get
free shipping and free returns 15% off a
watch that is as cool as this one and
they really do have very cool stuff they
have a wide varieties for men and women
really cool stuff okay so with all of
this said about how the right is better
than the left on Islamic terrorism even
the right is not willing to acknowledge
in many in many cases a basic fact and
that is the war by radical Islamic
civilization against the West is broader
than we like to pretend it is this is
what I was complaining about as far as
president from speech yesterday in Saudi
Arabia he talked about Islamic extremism
and then he sort of excused the Saudis
and he excused the
in the United Arab Emirates and today he
was making the statement that he made
about how terrorists are evil losers he
made that while standing next to Mahmoud
Abbas the dictator of the Palestinian
Authority
Malcolm Abbas is a terrorist Mahmoud
Abbas is a guy who financed the 1972
Munich Olympic terror attacks the Munich
Massacre
Mahmoud Abbas is a fellow who in 2015
like a year and a half ago said that
every drop of blood spilled in Jerusalem
by a Palestinian is worthwhile and they
are martyrs to Allah okay Trump was
standing next to that guy yesterday he
was standing next to him when he said
all of this and so when Trump says we'll
clip three that Israel and its Arab
neighbors they have a common interest in
stopping terrorism no that's really not
super true many Muslim nations have
already taken steps to begin following
through on this commitment there is a
growing realization among your Arab
neighbors that they have common cause
with you and the threat posed by Iran
and it is indeed a threat there is no
question about that I thank both you and
Prime Minister Netanyahu for your
commitment to achieving peace between
the Israelis and the Palestinians I also
look forward to discussing the peace
process with Palestinian President Abbas
okay now this is ridiculous Abbas is not
going to take part in a peace process
because the minute he signs a deal his
own people kill him he is currently in a
unity government with the terrorist
group Hamas is currently in a unity
government with the terrorist group
Islamic Jihad now the West likes to
pretend they like to pretend that
terrorism against Israel yesterday well
Trump was in Jerusalem there was an
attempted terror attack in Jerusalem but
with the left and the right everywhere
is this common attempt not not all of
the right but some of the right there's
this attempt to carve off Israel from
the battle against terrorism is that
when a Palestinian blows up a bunch of
children in a pizzeria or when a
Palestinian shoots a kid in a car that's
somehow difference in kind from the same
thing happening in the UK or France or
Germany that's just silly
there are a lot of people who like to
say well it's a territorial conflict the
palestinian-israeli conflict it's a
territorial thing no it isn't because of
Israel were to give up every slice of
territory all of
the battle wouldn't end Dave Israel were
to give up Jerusalem to the Palestinians
you know all of it you know what
happened the Palestinians would
immediately seek to kill as many Jews as
possible using that terrorists territory
as a launching point we know that
because that's exactly what they did in
1967 and in 1973 so the idea that they
are that this is a territorial conflict
here's the rule about territorial
conflicts if it were a territorial
conflict if you have a territorial
conflict it can be solved by territorial
solution if a territorial conflict
cannot be solved by territorial solution
it's not actually a territorial conflict
it's a religious conflict and yet the
right and the left apparently have this
common stake in pretending that terror
against Jews in Israel is somehow
markedly different than terror against
British people at a concert in the UK
and that is just not true that's why
you'll see Chris Matthews over on MSNBC
basically suggesting that Israel
deserves terrorism even though the rest
of the West doesn't but when you go over
there to deposit it in territories sure
there are terrorists and they should be
punished by the people over there that's
where I think they've got to act then
you have these Palestinian business guys
regular guys like us just regular people
they're peaceful they are being bothered
every day of their life to try to
business they have to sit there when
some Israeli soldier pointing his gun at
them for three or four hours at every
checkpoint they're humiliating those
people and once I call they're going to
blow Jim I don't want any sort so the
idea is that if you are forced as a
businessperson to go through the rigors
of a check by TSA because there are
terrorists getting on the flight you're
going to go and commit a terrorist
attack the idea that Israel is somehow
at fault here again I know that the left
is a little bit easier from the left
because what also blames the West for a
lot of terrorism the West but the idea
overall that the conflict between Israel
and Palestinians is somehow different
and that there is common cause between
Israel and the Palestinians in fighting
terror is just absolute nonsense
Prime Minister Benjamin Netanyahu had
this to say this morning regarding the
Manchester attack it is 100% true even
though people don't want to hear it I
want to thank you especially today for
your and as you said this morning mr.
president
funding and rewarding terrorism must end
standing next to you President Abbas
condemned the oolitic attack in
Manchester well I hope this heralds a
wheelchair
change because if the attacker had been
Palestinian and the victims had been
Israeli children the suicide bombers
family would have received a stipend
from the Palestinian Authority that's
Palestinian law that law must be changed
and not only that American taxpayers
will be paying for because we get to age
the Palestinian Authority then funneled
the terrorists the tailor for Sachs
which stops all this should immediately
be implemented in the United States
develop the terror attack in Manchester
is not about Israel but terrorist
attacks in Israel are about Manchester
and the idea that all of this is in part
of a broader civilizational battle with
radical Islamic terrorism that is
mistake and by ignoring that mistake all
you end up doing is promulgating the
terrorism by pretending away Abbas in
Saudi Arabia that they're all allies
with us against against things like what
happened in Manchester all you end up
doing is ignoring one of the sources of
the real problem and long term listen we
don't have the power to topple every bad
regime we don't have the ability or the
willingness to throw everybody out of
power who we don't like nor should we
because the fact is that sometimes what
replaces them is worse but if we don't
keep in mind who our enemies are
we're not going to take cautious
policies we're going to make foolish
mistakes like signing money over to bad
guys and then we're shocked when that
comes back to bite us in the ass whether
it's on 9/11 or whether it's in Israel
or whether it's in Manchester okay well
I want to talk a little bit more about
all of this house we want to talk about
what's going on in the so-called Russia
investigation a couple of bombshells
drop last night but in order for you to
see that you have to go over to Daley
wired.com right now become and subscribe
but for just eight dollars a month you
can become a subscriber over at Daley
whiter calm that means you get to see
the rest of the show live you get to be
part of the mailbag it means that right
and if you put an annual subscriber
right now they get a free signed copy of
a new book out from me and my dad this
is great for Father's Day
say it so it's all about me and my dad
and the 2005 White Sox championship
season if you love baseball it's a real
baseball book
Jerry kresnik from ESPN has endorsed
this as a great book dana perino mark
levin say it's a great book I also say
it's a great book but I wrote it say it
so by me and my dad you get a signed
copy I'll sign it for you absolutely
free of charge when you become your
annual subscriber to daily wire.com it's
the only way to get it right now is
becoming an annual subscriber to daily
wire.com we'll bring it out on Amazon
more publicly in a couple of weeks but
right now this is the only way you can
get a copy and a signed copy this is the
only way you can get it to go to go to
daily wire.com becoming an annual
subscriber you get a free signed copy of
say it so Papa dad and me and the 2005
Chicago White Sox championship season
whether you like the White Sox or not
I'm sure most people don't it's a great
baseball book and it's really about
father-son relationships more than
anything else sort of the Diaries me my
dad kept watch every game that season so
it's a lot of fun so daily wire.com for
all that if you just want to listen
later then go over to iTunes or
SoundCloud subscribe and leave review we
always appreciate it this is the largest
conservative podcast in the United
States
[Music]
you